foreign
equity loan is back yes home equity line
of credit HELOC the home equity line of
credit and uh life hacker says
I used one when I got in trouble so you
should everyone should have one in this
stupid butt article I remembered we'd
taken out a home equity line of credit
when we bought the house and it saved
our butts oh really oh really
his whole house is leveraged on this
money yeah so you know you know what a
home equity line of credit is explain it
for him Dave it's that
it's a second mortgage
and you know what they base the interest
rate on your credit nope whatever they
feel like when they wake up that morning
because it's variable it's completely
variable and it is not indexed to any
outside thing so Mr Banker says today
I think I'm going to charge join Susie
stupid money
so you mean to tell me
when I saw everybody in my neighborhood
redo their yard redo their kitchen redo
everything and I'm going where is this
money coming from
it's because they took advantage of
their home equity they leveraged that's
the word I like Dave they leverage well
I'm I'm sophisticated because my My
Equity otherwise was not working for me
and now I have new bushes
[Music]
yeah that's that's what the you know and
that's what the banking ads sound like
don't they I mean if you listen if you
listen to Sofi oh yeah it's smart money
so smart money moves I'm just gonna soap
I throw up right here oh my God man Dave
I told you this before the break it's a
good thing because I did so much stupid
stuff before I got a hold of of the
principles here if I had known about a
HELOC thank God I didn't know about this
because I would have just added it to
the list of dumb stuff right next to
co-signing alone yeah I would have put
HELOC yeah well here's the thing there's
a lot of idiot financial planners and
people like Lifehacker who will tell you
to get a home equity loan in case
there's an emergency now let's follow
this line of in air quotes logic
okay so you lose your job or you have
another Financial Calamity of some kind
so the home equity line is there to help
you you can go draw on it and you have
money
so at the moment that I've lost my job
or had a financial Calamity is precisely
the moment that I want to go deeper into
debt
this is the line of thought that's a
head scratcher yeah
so I you know I've had financial
planners talk about this for years and
I've had to just rip their rip them to
shreds because it's just so freaking
stupid not all of them do this but I
mean some of them will say open a home
equity line of credit don't use it and
use the fact that you can go tap into it
if you need to as your emergency fund
since and I always tell them so what I
want what do I want to do when there's
an emergency what I want to do is add to
the anxiety and the stress by going
deeper into debt right you're turning it
dumber than a rock
a rock it turns the emergency into a
crisis into a crisis because now you got
whatever it is that you're having to
deal with and you have to pay off the
debt and it's at a variable rate
of Interest so her point was is that
they had a uh they had a uh damaged
storm damage and they were able to use
their home equity loan to fix it because
apparently you don't know how to work
with your insurance company because if
you have storm damage and your roof's
leaking your insurance company will show
up start writing checks in about 36
minutes yeah
uh if you actually know how to talk to
them instead they didn't show up for you
you know why because you didn't need
them because you went into debt
yeah there's a lot underneath the
surface here on this article and let me
tell you what else happens every time
you do this crap right here okay house
gets torn up we use debt to fix the
house and we're going to pay off the
debt when the emergency when the
insurance check comes you know what you
always do a hundred percent of the time
people well 98 of the time people will
do more repairs to the house because
while we're at it we're gonna go ahead
and renovate then the insurance check
will cover so when the insurance check
comes it's not enough to cover because
we while we were at it we did some other
stuff yeah and that's an freaking nature
that's why I love in this article he
says the HELOC allowed us to get started
immediately if insurance won't show up
when the roof gets blown off your house
yeah
I mean really if you have an insurance
company on homeowners that will not show
up and give you help immediately when
there's storm damage you have other
issues that a HELOC won't fix you know I
wonder what would happen if you just
saved up
for emergencies oh wait
you had money if you just saved up oh
there's an idea I wish I'd have thought
of that and you had the amount we should
we should do a radio show about that
that's awesome idea and in your three to
six months you had the amount of your
homeowners insurance deductible and you
didn't have any payments and so while
you're at work you're making money
without any payments and you have an
emergency fund and then when you have a
crisis you have this thing called
money
that's a great idea Jade and you just go
what is it that sucks all right write a
check yeah that's all you do Dave
emergency fund turns a crisis into an
inconvenience
and
a home equity loan turns a crisis into
an opportunity to be crisis squared
double up triple up exponentially worse
so here's the here's you're not
sophisticated if you used a home equity
loan to cover your problems in life
you're broke
and there's nothing sophisticated about
being broke it's just dumb
okay
just dumb now I've been dumb and I've
been broke so stop being dumb stop being
broke we're going to walk you through
this and and you don't use well I I'm
I'm you know I'm utilizing the equity in
my home that otherwise would not be
working for me you're an idiot
okay when you say stuff like that you're
just an idiot because you are you're
truncating your most powerful wealth
building tool you're slowing your wealth
building down because you didn't have
any money to cover emergencies so
everyone should have an emergency fund
after they're out of debt except their
home baby step three of three to six
months of expenses we have been saying
that for 30 we've been saying that
longer than home equity loans have been
in existence they were not even in
existence when we started this radio
show 30 years ago they didn't make them
and now now we have a HELOC because he
lock sounds so well you're locked up I'm
a financial person of a HELOC you get a
heat lock you get locked into debt yeah
that's about it you know what I I think
somebody ought to complain why didn't
they call it a shelock
Dave don't go there yeah I think I just
got canceled somewhere in the universe
this is the Ramsay show